(beat boxing)
(football players yelling)
(rain pouring)
- Here we come son!
Here we come!
(players yelling)
(powerful adventurous music)
(powerful adventurous music
intensifying)
(helmet banging)
(high pitch note blaring)
(referee whistling)
- You feeling alright?
(football players cheering)
- What was going on there?
What are we doing out there,
huh?
Because I don't know.
No seriously, but what are we
doing?
What are we doing?
- Playing football.
- Okay, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's it man.
Playing football, y'all!
- Yo, Eqqsquizitine,
you need to let the medics
take a look at you, man.
- Dude, I'm alright, man.
I'm fine!
Shoot, I'm here and I'm
ready to do this man.
What about you all, man?
Do you want this?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah!
Do you want this?
I mean, all you have to do is
ask, man,
there's plenty of apple pie to
go around.
You want some apple pie brother?
- Apple pie?
- You want some apple
pie bother come on, man.
Who want a slice?
- Yo Eqqsquizitine,
ain't no apple pie, man,
that's your helmet.
- Hey, hey, hey, yo, yo, yo,
maybe you should just sit out
next play.
- Sit out next play?
- Yeah.
- Are you all sit out next play?
- Nah.
- You'll sit out next play?
I didn't think so.
I don't need to sit out the next
play,
I'm gonna tell you why, cause
all y'all.
Cause I know y'all got my back.
Y'all know what I see when I
look at you?
I'm gonna tell you what I see.
Grown men, who look like giants-
- Yeah.
- With really big shoulders.
- Who are wearing short pants.
- What?
- And just right there?
A few seconds of complete
darkness.
And then saw some real
floaty specs of light
in the air up like that.
- Eqqsquizitine.
- Who is that?
Is that Cartoons Plural talking
to me?
- Yeah.
- Cartoons Plural, where you at?
- I'm here, man.
- Oh yeah.
- You have a brain injury.
You need to get some medical
attention.
- Hey, I'm gonna tell you
right now Cartoons Plural,
who needs some medical attention
is the Tubers over there, right
there.
- Dog, dog, dog.
- What, what?
- We're playing the Bruises.
- Right, okay.
- Bruisers.
- Okay, listen y'all,
we need to remember who we are,
okay?
We're the team of destiny this
year.
We the team everybody talking
about,
we're the team everybody afraid
of man.
We gotta remember who we are.
Who are we?
- The Rhinos.
- Rhinos!
Who are we?
- Are we the Rhinos?
- Yeah!
- Oh my God, somebody stole our
horns.
We gotta find our horns y'all!
(Eqqsquizitine laughing)
(bleeping)
(tunnel whooshes)
- Welcome to the 2015
East/West Bowl Pro Edition.
Of all the all star games
in professional sports,
this one is sure to be
the most extravagant.
- That's right, these players
were selected by the fans too.
And when it comes to flare,
these characters are the crem de
la crem.
(intense metal music)
- Creme de la Creme,
Vanderbilt University.
- Cosgrove Shumway, Clemson.
- Ha Ha Clinton-Dix,
University of Alabama.
- Doink Ahahahue, Marshall.
- Legume Duprix with Virginia
University.
- Leger Dozable, University
of Central Florida.
- Quisperny G'Dunzoid Senior,
Central Connecticut State
University.
- Grunky Peep, Georgia
Southern University.
- D'Brickashaw Ferguson,
University of Virginia.
- Strunk Flugget, University
of South Carolina.
- Stumptavian Roboclick,
Grambling State.
- Cornelius "Tank" Carradine,
Florida, State University.
- Vogonius Thicket-Suede, Duke.
- Marmadune Shazdot,
TulaneUniversity.
- Swordless Mimetown,
Jacksonville State University.
- There is a lot of
talent in this game, Eric.
Let me tell you something,
when you look at players
like Marmadune Shazdot,
Ha Ha Clinton-Dix, and Strunk
Flugget,
you're looking at players
who made an impact this year.
- I mean is Ha Ha Clinton-Dix
even real?
This guy was amazing.
So solid all season long
for the Greenbay Packers.
And when you throw in
guys like Legume Duprix,
Swordless Mimetown, and
D'Brickashaw Ferguson,
this is surely gonna be
a squad for the ages.
- I agree, now let's meet
the players from the west.
- Prince Amukamara,
University of Nebraska.
- J.R. Junior Juniors, Jr.,
Texas Christian University
- Faux Doadles, University of
Oregon.
- Fozzy Whitaker, the University
of Texas
- Myriad Profiteroles, Utah.
- Busters Brownce, Illinois
State.
- Turdine Cupcake, (indistinct).
- Rerutweed Myth, (indistinct).
- Ishmaa'ily Kitchen,
Kent State University.
- Takitthu' Limit, College of
the Canyons.
- Snarf Mintx-Plasse,
East Los Angeles College.
- Frostee Rucker, University
of Southern California.
- Slendiferous Finch,
Northwestern University.
- Triple Parakeet-Shoes, Ball
State.
- Loghammer D'Baggagecling,
North Texas University.
- A.A. Ron Rodgers, Cal.
- [Bill] And we're coming to
the end of the first quarter
with the Rhinos in the red
zone for the first time.
- [Jeff] Gotta say Bill, I
like watching these Rhinos.
- [Bill] Ransom takes the snap,
drops back with good protection,
and that's a completed pass!
To a very wide open Hingle
McCringleberry,
the rookie outta of Penn State.
- [Jeff] Nice grab by
McCringleberry,
you think he's happy?
- [Bill] Oh boy, he is
loving it down there.
- [Jeff] Oh we got something
of a shooting gallery going.
- [Bill] Oh yeah, look at that.
Boy that is something and...
(referree whistles)
Oh, oh wait, we've got a flag
there.
Is that for excessive
celebration?
- [Jeff] Yeah.
- [Bill] Well see and I'm
not sure about that call.
- [Jeff] I don't know
Bill, that was three pumps
and the rule book says you
cannot have more than two.
- [Bill] Oh my gosh but look at
the kid.
He's pleading his case with the
ref.
Pleading his case.
- [Jeff] Yeah, clearly three
pumps.
- [Bill] Coach Johnson,
definitely not happy
about this call.
- [Bill] Five minutes into the
fourth quarter, third and 10.
The Rhinos again, threatening to
score.
Can the Cougars hold them?
- [Jeff] Big play coming here,
Bill.
- [Bill] Ransom takes
the snap, drops back.
He floats one into the end zone
and McCringleberry pulls it
down!
He's got it!
Oh my gosh,
for his second touchdown
of the day for this rookie,
he has gotta be feeling
great about himself.
- [Jeff] Nicely done,
I'll tell you man, he's...
- [Bill] Oh see now there's two
pumps.
- [Jeff] Yeah, he's really
testing the boundaries
and he is clearly gotten
the ref's attention here.
- [Bill] A third pump will
draw a flag no matter what.
See he just did it again!
Now wat is that, the second
time?
Now you have to flag him on
that.
- [Jeff] Yeah you had to.
You know Bill, it's just
frustrating seeing young players
without the ability to
restrain themselves.
Oh it really is, it's hard.
I mean the ref's gonna get you
every time.
- [Bill] Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
See, now the ref agrees,
that's three pumps right there.
And the quarterback Ransom,
under center.
Last five minutes of the game.
Rhinos are marching here again.
- [Jeff] hard to stop this
team from scorin' Bill.
They have so many weapons.
- [Bill] Ransom takes the snap
and it's a shovel pass to
McCringleberry!
Oh he's at the 10!
He's at the five and touched
down Rhinos!
- [Jeff] Oh my great
block by heartDonkasadsd.
And that's gonna be tough for
the Cougars to come back from.
- [Bill] Boy, what a career
day from Hingle McCringleberry,
the rookie outta Penn State.
Oh he was just amazingly
fired up here today, Jeff.
- [Jeff] You gotta love the way
this guy plays and he, oh...
- [Bill] See now there's one
pump oh...
Well, I cannot believe this kid.
- [Jeff] You gotta put your team
first
in situations like this
and McCringleberry's just not
doing that.
- [Bill] Well now there's two
Jeff.
Now, if he pumps a third time
he will draw his third penalty
for today.
Everybody here waiting with
batted breath.
- [Jeff] He did it.
- [Bill] Oh, did he?
- [Jeff] Yes he did.
- [Bill] Oh that's he
couldn't help himself.
It's amazing.
I mean, come on in professional
football, it's really-
- [Jeff] It's a shame, that's
what it is.
- [Bill] Yes, yes it is.
- [Jeff] You can argue all you
want,
but the flag, well it's
been thrown that's right.
- [Bill] Thats right, if it's
three pumps,
the ref's not gonna take it away
now.
- [ Jeff] No, he's not.
Duration and intensity
doesn't make any difference.
- [Bill] Well, Jeff let's
have a look at the replay here
to see if indeed he
did do the three pumps.
- [Jeff] All right, no question.
There is the first one.
- [Bill] Yeah.
- [Jeff] Right?
- [Bill] Agreed, right.
- [Jeff] And then coming
up is the second one.
- [Bill] Okay yes, very clear.
It's the third.
- [Jeff] We'll see it.
It's coming up right here.
- [Bill] I'm just not usre.
Oh yeah, you're right.
There's absolutely three pumps
there.
Oh, apologies to all those
watching with young children
clearly unintentional.
- I'm Dave Sassin alongside Jeff
Worthing,
and welcome to the 2013,
East/West Bowl,
where we're going to be watching
some of the best college
athletes in the nation
try to put last year's spectacle
to shame.
- That's right, Dave.
It won't be easy but this year's
seniors
certainly will be trying
to give last year's stars
a run for their money.
Let's check out the team,
starting with the players from
the east.
(energetic metal music)
- Coznesster Smiff, Rutgers
University.
- Ellipses Corter, University of
Alabama.
- Nyquillus Dillwad, LSU.
- Bismo Funyuns, Florida State
University.
- Decatholac Mango,
Georgia Tech University.
- Mergatroid Skittle,
University of Louisville.
- Quiznatodd Bidness,
University of Tennessee.
- D'Pez Poopsie, Ole' Miss.
- Quackadilly Blip, Auburn
University.
- Golius Boozler, The U.
- Bisquiteen Trisket,
University of Michigan.
- Fartrell Cluggins,
University of Arkansas.
- Blyrone Blashington, Syracuse.
- Cartoons Plural, Virginia
Tech.
- Jammie Jammie-Jammie,
the Ohio State University.
- Fudge.
- Some of the big stories this
year
the meteoric rise of D'Pez
Poopsie,
and let's not forget about
Heisman Winner,
Jammie Jammie-Jammie.
- And remember you can't talk
about 2013
without bringing up Fudge.
Everybody's talking about Fudge.
At 350 pounds, this running back
is almost unstoppable the whole
year.
- You're right, I could
talk about Fudge all day,
but first let's meet the
players from the west.
(powerful rock music)
- Equine Ducklings, Indiana
University,
Purdue University, Indianapolis.
- Dahistorius Lemystorius,
Utah State University.
- Ewokoniad Sigorneth
Juniorstein,
Oklahoma State University
- Eqqsquizitine Buble-Schinslow,
University of Nebraska.
- Huka'lakanaka
Hakanakaheekalucka'hukahakafaka,
University of Hawaii.
- King Prince Chambermaid,
Baylor University.
- Ladennifer Jadaniston,
University of Colorado
- Ldadadaladadadadada
Dala-Dadaladaladalada,
University of Arizona.
- Harvard University, DeVry
University.
(Morse beeping)
- Army Navy Surplus Store.
- Wingdings, online classes.
- Firstname Lastname, College
University.
- God, homeschooled.
- Sweeeeeeeeeeps, Santa Monica
college.
- Benedict Cumberbatch, Oxford
University.
- A.A. Ron Balakay, Morehouse
College.
(intense music)
- Hi everybody, I'm Dave Sassin,
alongside Jeff Worthy
and welcome to the annual
East/West Bowl,
as we get ready to watch
some of the best college
players in the nation
showcase their skills
in a classic showdown
between east and west.
And there really are some
characters on this year's
squads.
Aren't there, Jeff?
- That's right, Dave,
it does seem like the most
flamboyant personalities
came to the forefront and they
are here.
Let's meet the players from the
east.
- D'Marcus Williums,
University of Georgia.
- T.J. Juckson, Wayne State
University.
- T'variusness King, Marymac
college
- Tyroil Smoochie-Wallace,
University of Miami.
- D'Suarius Green, Jr.,
University of Notre Dame.
- Ibrahim Moizoos, University
of Tennessee at Chattanooga.
- Jackmerius Tacktheritrix,
Michigan State University
- D'Isiah T. Billings-Clyde,
Coastal Carolina University.
- D'Jasper Probincrux III,
South Carolina State University.
- Leoz Maxwell Jilliumz,
Wast Carolina University.
- Javaris Jamar Javarison-Lamar,
University of Middle Tennessee.
- Davoin Shower-Handel,
University
of Southern Mississippi.
- Hingle Mcringleberry,
Penn State University
- L'Carpetron Dookmarriot,
Florida Atlantic University.
- J'Dinkalage Morgoone,
University of South Florida.
- Xmus Jaxon Flaxon-Waxon,
California University of
Pennsylvania.
- We're going to be looking
for big plays all game long
from Tyroil Smoochie-Wallace.
- And let's not forget the tight
ends,
Ibrahim Moizoos, and
Hingle McCringleberry,
they've both had amazing
seasons.
- That's right, Jeff.
Now let's meet the players from
the west.
(energetic rock music)
- Saggitariutt Jefferspin, Texas
A&M.
- D'Glester Hardunkichud,
University of Wisconsin.
- Swirvitan L'Goodling-Splatt,
Saskatchewan University.
- Quatro Quatro, San
Jose State University.
- Ozamataz Buckshank, Stanford
University.
- Beezer Twelve
Washingbeard, Jones College.
- Shakiraquan T.G.I.F. Carter,
University of Northern Arizona.
- X-Wing @aliciousness, Missouri
Western State University.
- Sequester Grundleplith M.D.,
Adam State.
- Scoish Velociraptor Maloish,
South Dakota State University.
- T.J. A.J. R.J.
Backslashinfourth
V, AlbienCollege.
(Eeeee squeeling)
- San Diego State University.
- Donkey Teeth, Boise State
University
- Torque (jackjammer jmamer)
Lewith, Nevada State
Penitentiary.
- The player formerly known as
Mousecop,
University of Missouri,
Columbia.
- Dan Smith, BYU.
(glitchy jazz music)
£ Oh I want it £
£ But I don't need ya £